네 안녕하세요 오늘은 동대문에 대해서
좀 설명드리려고 하는데 여러분들
동대문 하면 아마 기억나시는게 있으실
것 같습니다 옷을 구매하러 좀 많이
가셨을 것 같은데 그만큼 동대문이
이런 패션 쪽으로 좀 많이 발달이
되어 있었습니다 이런 대형 쇼핑몰
건물들도 많이 밀집되어 있었고 주변에
도매시장도 많이 있었는데 처음에 옷장
사하시는 분이 여기 도매 시장가
가지고 옷을 싸게 떼와서 어 인터넷
쇼핑몰로 이렇게 판매하는 경우가
많았거든요 그래서 동대문 도매 시장도
굉장히 좀 발달이 돼 되어 있었습니다
대한민국에서 옷을 구매하면 무조건
와야 되는 곳 중에 하나였는데 그게
이제
1990년대부터 2000년도 초반
때까지 대한민국을 대표하는 그런 패션
성지라고 불릴 정도로 많은 사람들이
찾기 시작했는데 이런 곳이 최근에
많은 어려움을 겪고 있다라고 합니다
그래서 이런 대형 쇼핑몰 건물의
특징은 호수가 여러 가지로 쪼개져
있습니다 분양을 할 때 수익성을
극대화하기 위해서 이렇게 잘게 잘게
쪼개서 매각을 했습니다 그러다
보니까이대 쇼핑몰 한 건물에 소유자가
진짜 몇백명이 되는 거예요
테크노마트도 아마 비슷할 거 같아요
그래서 저희 뭐 전자 기기를
구매하거나 휴대폰을 구매하기 위해서
테크노마트를 많이 갔는데 지금
테크노마트도 공실률이 매우 심각하고
좀 거기 분위기도 많이 안 좋아진
걸로 알고 있습니다 테크노마트뿐만
아니라 뭐 밀리오레 APM 그리고
굿모닝시티 뭐 이런 쇼핑몰 큰 것들은
다 집합 건물로 되어 있어요 이런
건물들의 또 특징은 위치가 너무
좋아요 대부분 이런 대형 쇼핑몰
건물들은 역세권 에 위치하고 있습니다
그래서 우리가 얘기하는 그런 입지
좋은 부동산 조건을 다 가치고
있습니다 위치가 너무 좋은데도
불구하고 공실률이 50% 넘어갑니다
그래서 실제로는 그거보다 더 높은 거
같아요 심지어 공실률이 너무 높다
보니까 임대료를 안 받는 경우도
있거든요 들어와서 관리비만 내라고
하는데도 임대가 안 채워지고 있습니다
그래서 일단은 공실의 원인을 좀
파악해 보면은 우선 첫 번째로 소비
패턴이 바뀐 거예요 예전에는 노사로
매장에 와서 직접 보고 구매하는 경우
가 많았었는데 요즘에는 다 인터넷으로
구매하거나 이런 오프라인 매장을 좀
안 오게 됐던 그런 부분이 제일 큰
거 같습니다 그 두 번째로는 이게
되게 핵심인데 이에 관계자가 너무
많아요이 한 건물에 소유자가 몇백
명이에요 그래서 뭘 바꾸려고 해도이
협의가 안 됩니다 관리를 잘할 수가
없어요 어떻게 보면 그 수백명의
소유자 중에 관리비를 제대로내는
사람이 많지는 않을 것 같거든요
그중에 안내는 사람들도 있고 안내는
사람이 많은데내는 사람은 되게 좀
그렇잖아요 불합리하고 그러다 보니까
소유자들 그리 싸우는 경우도 되게
많아요 그런 부분에 있어서 관리가 좀
되게 어렵습니다 사실 동대문이
입지적으로 되게 괜찮은 곳이거든요
동대문 자체가 그 DDP 또
외국인들이 많이 오거든요 인건
상권에도 어찌됐든 흡수가 돼요 근데
외국인 관광객이 지금 뭐 밀리 오레나
뭐 굿모닝 시티나 막 이런 데보다
두타몰 다 몰려 있습니다 그래서
그거는 여러분들이 직접 가서 보시면
확실히 느끼실 거예요 뭐 임차인
fmb 구성이 이라든지 1층의 임차인
구성이라는 상부층 보면은 임차인이
되게 요즘 트렌드에 맞게 다 잘 차
있거든요 그거와 반해서 뭐 밀리
오래라는 APM 이라든지 실제로가
보시면 1층에도 들어가기 싫게 돼
있어요 눈에도 잘 안 띄고 옛날에는
정말 바글바글 했는데 지금에는인 차인
구성도 제대로 안 돼 있고 관리도 좀
잘 안 되고 이런게 너무 아쉽습니다
그래서 지금 두타몰 비교해서
APM이나 밀리오리 굿모닝 시티가
위치가 더 괜찮다라고 보거든요 근데
그 관리에 대한 부분 운영에 대한
부분 이해 관계인이 많는 부분이랑
그냥 한 업체가 하는 거에 따라
차이가 엄청 큽니다 제가 분양 상가를
계속 권하지 않는 이유가 바로 그런
거예요 그니까 이해 관계인이 너무
많고 쪼개져 있고 어 내 마음대로 뭘
할 수가 없고 그리고 공실이 나면
관리비는 계속 내야 되고 매각하기도
쉽지 않고 보통 이제 수익률에 따라서
매각을 하는데 임차인이 나가게 되면
임대 수익뿐만 아니라 그 매매 가격도
같이 줄어듭니다 그런 것 때문에 분양
상가는 저는 굉장히 좀 위험하다 라고
생각을 합니다 그래서 항상 이런 집합
건물 분양 상가를 매입할 때 이해
관계자가 많은 경우에는 정말 리스크가
크다라고 생각하고 아무리 입지가
좋다라고 하더라도 이런 운영 문제
아니면 이해 관계인이 많은 문제
때문에 승패가 좌우될 수도 있습니다
이거는 빌딩 투자도 똑같은 거 같아요
그래서 아무리 위치가 좋다 하더라도
관리를 제대로 하지 못하거나 어
제대로 운영하지 못하는 경우에는
건물마다 차이가 클 수 있습니다
그래서 여러분들 빌딩 투자도 단순하게
투자가 아니라 어떻게면 임대 사업을
하는 거예요 그래서 어떻게 운영할
건지 계획을 잘 짜야지 최대로 활용이
가능하게 만들 수 있어요 말씀드렸던
곳이 다 역세권이고 위치는 굉장히
좋기 때문에 이해 관계인을 좀
최소화하고 운영 관리만 할 수 있다면
저는 충분히 살아날 수 있을 것
같습니다 대표적인 사례로 명동 밀리
오래를 예로 들 수 있을 것 같아요
입지적으로 너무 훌륭한 곳인데
327개 매장이 있었어요 이해관계인이
많아서 운영 자체가 잘 되지
않았습니다 그래서 명동 상권인데
불구하고 정말 죽은 건물이라 그랬어요
되게 어두운 건물 그러다가 한 업체가
몇 년에 걸쳐서 소유자 208명을
직접 찾아가서 두시간 동안
프레젠테이션을 하셨대요네 그래서 정말
엄청난 시간이 걸렸고 심지어
중환자실까지가 가지고 설득을 했다라고
합니다 정말 그 업체는 진짜
존경합니다네 그래서 진짜 그렇게
우열곡절 끝에 해 가지고 그
300개가 넘는 매장을 아홉 개
매장으로 바 고 그렇게 완전 탈바꿈이
됐다라고 합니다 그 건물 진짜 죽어
있던 건물 자체가 그렇게 운영 주체가
바뀌 인해서 확 달라졌습니다이
밀리오레 명동 밀리오레 사례가 되게
대표적인 성공 사례라고 생각합니다
근데 우리가 부동산 투자할 때 사실
입지만 보고 많이 사잖아요 근데 방금
보여 드린 사례처럼 뭐 두타몰
비교해서 뭐 밀리의 뭐 APM 구모닝
시티 럼이 관리하는 운영에 따라서
부동산 투자 승패가 자지 유지될
정도로이 운영에 대한 부분도 한번 좀
심각하게 고민을 해 봐야 되고 그리고
이해 관계인이 많은 부동산은 그만한
가치를 못 받을 수도 있겠구나 아니면
부동산에 좀 문제가 발생될 수도
있겠구나라는 부분도이 사례를 통해서
생각해 보셨으면 좋겠습니다네 오늘
영상은 여기까지 하겠습니다 빌딩은
역시 빌사남